[Music]
exhales this review is brought to you by
iron Lords podcast part of the strain
team and your yours truly Lord at it I'm
the one that's going to be going ahead
and reviewing it for those of you that
know I have been playing a little bit of
this of extreme and I think I've done
two strains maybe one that I don't quote
me yeah if you quote me I'm not gonna
care either way
but you know thanks for the people over
a fundamental to much anime I think for
the people over there at a Funko they
sent us the review code for it and you
know coming from someone that doesn't
really play these type of games because
I really don't to be to be frequently
honest with you guys the other game
though I feel like the game it was
inspired from to compete with it was art
the survival art game and that game had
one of the worst case scenarios with me
possible because when I played that game
the worst stuff that could possibly
happen to you always happened to you so
I wanted to point that out to you coming
from someone that doesn't really play
these games a whole lot I don't at all I
wanted to go ahead and give you some of
the you know the the likes I did I
played it for a couple hours I don't
think I'm gonna play too much more
because you know there's a lot of good
games coming out probably play it once
all these holiday games rush comes
through maybe after Kingdom Hearts 3 but
Conan X hours is you know that survival
experience game it's a really fun game
actually I played it by myself and I was
enjoying myself
I was streaming at 2 as well so that
might have contributed to some of the
enjoyment for the game but I feel like
this game runs better than art does and
I didn't have any of those like game
breaking issues and arc I had a couple
experiences with some it uh some
players on the field one gave me a bunch
of stuff so the community for the game
is pretty good I enjoyed that I did come
across another two individuals I don't
know exactly what goes went on with them
they didn't really attack me head-on or
anything like that so definitely
appreciate that because I think it could
have went really bad but you know what I
appreciate the most about this game is
the attention to detail I think that
they could do a little bit better when
it comes to exactly how they explain the
game to you because it took me a couple
minutes to really figure that out during
the so that hurt it a little bit on my
standpoint and it play a whole lot when
it comes to team play and this is a team
orientated game I want everyone to be
aware of that but as far as the team
orientated game I feel like if I play
this with a few more people I'd enjoy it
a lot more so I first thing I want to
say if anyone buys this game I
definitely make sure some of your
friends have it because these games
floors when you have other people to
play the fighting systems pretty nice I
actually enjoy the fighting system it's
a lot more in detail than Ark was I
don't know if they've changed or since
the last time I played it I don't think
I've played it since the beta well you
know since it was in game preview on
xbox I am reviewing this on NS I don't
know if there's any enhancements on the
X so keep that in mind as well but you
know all I want to say is Bravo I can't
remember exactly who developed the game
but you know definitely hate that I that
slipped my mind but you know I
appreciate everything that comes through
thank you for the review code the game
is definitely fun the gaming addict I'm
out of here peace
oh maybe
hold up oh and there was fire all that
that's some weird-ass fire
what did fire start becoming powerful
I feel like this is some witchcraft fire
I don't even feel comfortable using I
got it right here oh dude look how he
puts that this and this dude is not
joking around
I got stolen Oh
oh snap over and convert again
drop I don't need that any trees I could
probably any trees where's me some trees
I'm in the desert though so I just want
to point out that I'm looking for trees
in a desert so I don't know how this is
gonna work
catch people on fire look at that is
there a map in this game right there
they spawned me in the desert it looks
like there's different biomes I don't
know if I can make it trees
oh there's trees over there
found me some wood
oh no I gotta get some of this stone I
don't know man I'm liking this game word
I was like an art already damn they
don't take much does it
I got a bunch too would now okay
would my probably weighs more to bed
keep that in mind we just get rid of a
stack of wood
Oh see I was wasn't even paying
attention man this is what I'm talking
about look at this nice green area like
who wants to be in a desert look at this
nice green area and then what more
desert I don't even want to leave this
green area let me let me make a camp
right here there's a shrine okay I don't
I got that that's for sure
water skin I don't even know what that's
used for
what was that sound
I don't like that sound probably in my
head
what is this oh great oh great
you'll do just no no I don't got nothing
to hit you with look at you a little
climb really belong in you yo ass Oh II
didn't do nothing really not that strong
though what do you doing dude is this
what your life consists of I'm two feet
of Friday you there why can't you hit me
I don't think I'm supposed to fight this
dude but he's so slow man I feel a
complaint Zelda right now there's no way
he can let's go around the tree
I'm not even running fast and with a man
without a breath with your life oh oh no
I don't know what that is I'm out look
like a dog of some sort I think the dogs
probably faster than I am I feel like
I'm not strong enough to fight this
thing let me kick him oh look at that
when my foot is stronger than my ass
there's something wrong with the game
get it back yep I yeah that's right
ain't [ __ ] what does they call this
thing hold up just a corpse
I want to like talking on the name of
that weird ass thing
all right
now what is this alright so this is how
I make a selling foundation see what a
foundation is
I don't know how I feel about you coming
that close to me dude are you gonna
attack me like your punk-ass friend did
no attacking okay we good then
no I don't want to I don't want to look
at him huh let me look at this real
quick
wrote a
all right so apparently I built the
wrong thing let's just build a wedge
stood a frame let's build a frame you
see how that goes let's build a frame
spill two frames feel comfortable with
frames I don't know why you need an
existing piece to snap it on to all
right
they gotta be all weird and [ __ ] but you
know okay
a roof corner a sloth rough a right so
let's see if I can build onto this is
that a hex a repair hammer
there's a rough
oh my gosh
- drop it yeah I dropped it that was an
accident
I don't even know how to pick it up
okay
dropped it again what what am i doing
man what am i doing right bumper info
okay so it's the starting more this is
the one I need
how do I interact with this returned
item returned out there we go
right up on four
how do I
this is ridiculous I'm just gonna build
another one because apparently that's
easier
why can't I build this it says it's a
good starting point
requires landscape this is landscape Oh
okay still won't let me build it
oh I know how to build can I build off
of this seems a little bit too big I
think I messed up but
this is my house you guys this is my
house
what is what is that they got some stuff
to be doing in this game
psycho mode I gotta increase it
right there Phil fine
all right can i all right
not enough resources what am I missing
she's not got enough wood let's get some
real quick
[Applause]
I hear something
all right so you can't tear stuff down
that easy there's got to be a way you
can
kind of move that up a little bit
so it has to be like that
alright return item return item
[Music]
what is that sound
[Music]
I'm like petrified right now I don't
know what's going on as long as they
stay over there I'm cool with them
you guys stay away from me
[Music]
huh all right let's see
need more of those walls
well I want to let me build more okay
got no stone I guess could have just
told me that game be like yo you got no
stone
bill 17 should be plenty
yeah I always always do decent when it
comes to creative stuff decent not like
no dizzy or anything like that these is
a freaking nature when it comes to these
kind of games well that's just terrific
how can I
all right so let me see what else I can
get with these feats requires that and I
have to make a pickaxe decorations
I need that got that got to have it now
why can't I build it weapons
archery warrior let's get the warrior
see how the warrior stuff looks probably
looks really bad
Stone sword oh I got no stones what am I
missing
you get crazy crap on this like mad fast
I want to make a chest how do I make a
chest teaches wooden box there we go so
I asked for in this world what is that
sound man I feel like I'm a [ __ ] a
built stuff here I feel like that's
gonna be an issue I'm gonna get ate when
I like sleep or something at week
a branch alright it says I need a twine
I don't know where that is
maybe I have to build it
yeah I do at the Builder
gotta build it building it maybe you
make this stuff quick they should just
make it really instantly then whoa what
was that oh okay
all right so let's go ahead and build
that storage unit pick out this wood
all right so now
how do i okay there it is
return this
that didn't work the way I was hoping it
would
there we go
open your that
seeds there we go
things are coming along quite nicely
yeah I just had to get some stuff to do
that oh my god
why are you flown
Oh what is this
I feel like you're gonna kill me the
moment the moment you you give me this
stuff look
can I even put this stuff on
a glowing stick dude hooked me up that
never would have happened in uh
and art they just would have killed me
and our just want to point that out
people and our car [ __ ] well to me I
don't know about anyone else I like this
where'd that dude go
not enough resources okay
that's why I have to say but you're not
enough resources I still don't have
enough resources
stone and wood
I'm not going to keep just clicking this
over and over again
was built three what do you mean my next
project just curious like the next thing
I'm going to play or what
just working out
can't do this in art
[Music]
come on I dare someone come up here so
they chest not a player though not a
play I don't have enough stone oh I
don't I don't know to be honest with you
I don't know how to play the game that
well yeah
man you don't take much you getting
covered on this guy that's cool
spilt seven
since I don't write a destroy stuff I
guess I'll just add on to it
a huddle
oh I got me a little little shack I just
got a how do I destroy stuff oh my my
throat feels dry oh you know how to get
water on this guy oh look
oh there's two of them
why is just hitting them so much damage
my cycle just simple whatever the hell
it is
ow it's unnecessary man oh man the
fighting on this game is way better I'm
sorry
[Music]
nothing on them
I should have probably built one or two
more windows oh wow need a foundation
she does I need a stone pickaxe this
thing here
[Music]
can't fire
I don't know how to use these man
okay I don't know how to got a
I gotta get me water I don't have the
slightest idea of how to do that oh
great a little baby one little baby look
you stay your way I'll stay my way man
no reason for us to attack each other or
you can just attack me how oh you don't
like the fire to be fondest if you man I
don't like to fire you what is that
it looks scary looks like a crocodile
careful it's a trap is it coming after
me
no I can't see me from down there what
is that oh it is coming after me
what is that
you got that look wicked I gotta go
check that out
usually when you see stuff on like giant
fireballs attack and stuff I usually
stay away
sound
I don't simmer my own I fought my own
fight I'm clearly about to get rekt Oh
[Music]
I come in peace I don't know what I'm
doing I come in peace you got a tiger
there man
take two other tiger to chill and a
rhino
this is where that fireball thing came
from
hey know what I don't know how to do
that man hold up I don't like that pose
you done just did man
are you trying to hit me
oh this is unnecessary I don't have
anything
that [ __ ] looks awesome I admire I get
the point man I'll leave I get the point
I'm out that go ahead follow me don't
you give me some water man I'll be on my
way
give me some water okay okay I got you
I'm going you and your black armor that
looks like you should belong in sky
I don't get could I drink this water
over here though looks like it's part of
an ocean
can I drink it
okay
subdued
you're gonna go through this again we
know you don't like the fireman this is
not necessary
I don't even know how to get back to my
crib
and back
broken vases I built these vases you
also all hell no hell no look man I'm
working out alright
do my lips broken faces
yes I built this
cost - how many dark I doesn't really
tell you does
I could use some armor
I don't need that I'm gonna build it
anyway
did I build this I don't know how to um
I don't know how to like break stuff
down so like right now when it's up its
up for me
there should be a will to tear it down a
will and why are you saying should I
don't like how you saying should man I
feel like should means you don't know
what you're talking about I like to hold
X oh there we go
I like how it leaves the debris it's
probably gonna disappear here in a
second but that's cool yeah
of course and humble and comfort didn't
even go anyway
use a pic together bank from the tree
let me
I don't like how like unpredictable this
is
now how do I make doors
and let me see here a simple wooden door
those things must be heavy
like to know how you carry this stuff
can you build like staircases
just selling can't use that
it's not on
all right
[Music]